get ready because i'm going to show you
how to make a super umami flatbread but
before we start let's talk about new
mommy it's the fifth taste and it's
something that actually brings a lot of
flavor to food and kind of makes things
a bit more craveable we're going to
focus on shitake today dried shitake is
actually deliver some of the highest
concentration of umami possible what
we're going to do is we're going to take
these dried shitake and we're going to
grind them up so that they're easily
incorporated with the flour to make the
flatbread so here we have that quarter
cup of powdered dried shiitakes we also
have a tablespoon of kosher salt a
teaspoon and a half of active dry yeast
water a cup and a quarter and we're
going to just need this guy for about
five minutes
I don't know about you guys but I'm
starting it hungry so let's get over the
stove and get these guys cooking we're
going to let it cook for about two
minutes per side I think we're looking
pretty good here I think it's ready to
come off okay so now we've got this
great and flatbread and we have a lot of
options of both what you can do if it's
practically the blank canvas but I love
roasted vegetables so that's what I'm
going to do so all right I think that's
it here you have it shitake flatbread
now it's your turn experiment with your
own version and find out why science can
be fun and tasty